Your advice is there they
are kind of fatherly.
Is that something that comes with the
territory of being a psychologist or is
this your wife would say?
Well it's both.
Both being a professor at least in
principle and being at psychologist,
a clinical psychologist.
So I'm at a hybrid of those two things.
And I was also trained like I've read,
um,
deeply in the clinical literature,
psychoanalytic,
existential humanist,
there's all sorts of different
streams of clinical thinking,
all of which have something
very valuable to offer,
I would say.
But I was trained technically
as a behavioral psychologist
and one of the things
that are behavioral psychologist
is trained to do is to
take a large problem and
to break it down into units that
are small enough to actually manage
practically.
And so I've always considered my teaching
in that light is my goal is to take
high level abstractions and to break
them down until they're practically
applicable.
And so I suppose so that,
that's,
that's both educational.
So that's the professorial side
and psychologically meaningful.
So that's the clinical psychology side
because clinical psychologists fortify
the individual,
that's really their role.
And to the degree that
that's a fatherly role?
Well partly that's a consequence of
the fact that I have been a father.
I still am and that um,
I'm of the age where that's an appropriate
way of interacting with people,
but it's also in the same
category in some sense as like,
because the purpose of a
father psychologically is to
fortify the courage of his
children.
And so that's appropriate for me given
the stage of the development of my
career.
For example,
you talked about the importance for people
to sort out early on where they want
to go with their life.
Why is this important?
Yeah,
well we've done some
practical work on this too.
I have this program
called future authoring,
which is part of the self authoring suite
and it's available to everyone online.
I developed with my colleagues about 15
years ago and our goal was to produce
high quality psychological interventions
for mass audiences at an extremely low
cost and to do it in a way that was least
likely to cause negative consequences.
So that was the framework and the futuring
future authoring program helps people
develop a vision for their life.
And so you're asked to imagine that you
were taking care of yourself properly,
so you're taking
responsibility for yourself,
not taking the easy way out or or being
nice to yourself or bolstering your self
esteem or any of that,
but taking responsibility for your life
and that and envision who you could be
if you could be who you should be
three to five years down the road.
Just to ask yourself,
well,
if I could have what I wanted and
needed and if I was acting in the world
properly,
what would my friendships look like?
What would my intimate
relationship look like?
How would I conduct myself
with regards to my family?
I've had lots of people
come to my talks and say,
look,
I've really been trying
to put together my family.
We were fragmented badly,
and so I've been working for two years
to bring everyone together and it's
really working.
It's like people tell
me that all the time,
which is lovely thing to hear.
What?
How should you construct your career?
How should you educate yourself,
how you should resist temptation,
the temptation of drugs and alcohol.
Take care of yourself
mentally and physically.
Just have an image of if the
world could be set up around you,
starting with you in a way that would
be best for you and for other people as
well,
what would that look like?
What without that sort of vision,
you don't have a target and
you don't have any hope.
And like people live on hope
and your aim gives you hope.
And so the nobler your aim,
the more hope you have and you need hope,
especially during times of catastrophe.
And so it's extremely necessary for
people to consider their character
development because that's actually what
sustains them through the difficulties
of life.
And it seems as if we've,
we've either never knew this in our
education system or have forgotten it
completely and we can't forget that
because that's actually the purpose of
education.
The purpose of education is
the development of character.
It's not the,
it's not mastery over a set of facts.
Even though there's some
utility in that mastery,
if the facts are dead,
if they're just lying there and they're
not given life by being integrated into
a,
a noble narrative,
let's say,
then there of no utility,
they might even be harmful.
So,
and we've done research,
um,
if university students do
the future authoring program,
it decreases the probability they'll
drop out of school by about 30%.
And it seems to have a particularly
large effect on under achieving men.
And we're not sure
exactly why that gender,
uh,
differential exist.
But it might partly be because in the
main women are outperforming men in
academic environments.
And so these programs seem to boost
the performance of the lower lower
performers.
But it also might be that
men in particular won't
engage in the world properly
unless they have their own aims.
Yeah.
I was almost going to ask,
why do you think men are until
achieving or not living up to?
I think,
well,
I think part of it is the,
the contamination of competence with
tyranny is that if every time you turn
around,
when you're attempting
to win a competition,
for example,
or take your place in the world,
the implicit or explicit accusation
is that you're exercising tyranny and
participating in an oppressive patriarchy.
And there's something wrong
with you ethically for doing so.
It's hardly,
it's an invitation to the weak part
of your character to take over.
It's like,
well,
why should I try to do
anything when everything I do
is criticized and when I'm,
when I'm regarded?
And,
and it's not only that,
because like I've met many men who really
believed that their ambitions to take
their place in the world are part of
the oppressive patriarchal structure.
That's,
that's,
that's responsible for,
for the dispossession of the
dispossessed and the destruction of the,
of the ecological landscape.
And that their best bet was just to do
nothing just to sit there and do nothing
because at least then they'd be
harmless as if harmlessness is the most,
is the highest possible goal.
But if everything is oppressive power and
that's wrong than powerlessness is the
most impressive goal,
but there's no life in that.
So I'm going to sit here and be harmless.
So like I said,
this has become a mainstream view.
Uh,
I feel like,
what,
what do you think?
This isn't the hate can old completely.
There's certainly no shortage of pressure
to make it become the mainstream will
view.
Well,
this is where I think to the universities
play a terrible role because the
universities have facilitated
the development of these
activists disciplines,
women's studies,
probably foremost among them.
Um,
but social work,
anthropology,
often,
uh,
English literature has
become completely corrupt.
Law is heading in that direction.
Um,
and you have one fifth of
social scientists identifying
themselves as Marxists,
which I think is beyond reprehensible
given the history of Marxism and this,
this patriarchal,
uh,
what would you say?
This conceptual scheme that insists
that Western cultures are fundamentally
oppressive?
Patriarchies has become not only
like holy writ in the universities,
but it's spilling out into the
mainstream with incredible rapidity.
And it's an absolutely horrible doctrine.